you are most powerful most important is
when we just embrace who we are you win
by being you but you don't know who you
is yet I only got one life this is not a
dress rehearsal can I remind you of that
you don't get a chance to do this life
over again this is the show rise and
shine it's in spresso time good morning
believe nation it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift inside to you
that i want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message embrace who you are over
to you Dwayne the rock Johnson by way I
need one more chance to prove that I'm
good to be 8 maybe Greek God because
that's what other favorite part of the
film were kind of like is here is he not
exactly know which I love that's the new
take cuz you're gonna leave it like
believe in yourself that's the is just
believing in yourself and embracing who
you were born to be so by the way like
you're biracial and biracial right on
black Samoan like why exactly so often
to hybrids right and oftentimes like
when you're younger you know we
struggles sometimes the identity I wish
it was a little bit more like that or I
wish I wasn't different but you know
overall the message of Hercules how I
bring this whole thing back around is
you are most powerful most important is
when we just embrace who we are as Oscar
Wilde said be yourself everyone else is
taken I think this is really really
valuable advice because I believe in
Marlins success I believe that you can
learn from the people around you and
from people who've accomplished
something it's the name of my channel on
YouTube modeling the Masters
I love surrounding myself with all these
different people who've accomplished
great things and I learned from
everybody that I've profiled on my
channel if I don't learn for them I
don't feature them but through all of
that I had to figure out who I am I'm
not gonna win the exact same way that
Steve Jobs won my goal is not to be the
next Steve Jobs in your
shouldn't be either it's to figure out
who the best version of yourself is and
so if I'm posting a top 10 video on all
these different people the more you
surround yourself with those kinds of
people the more just that success
mindset is gonna seep in but your goal
is to be able to take one or two things
that was in that top 10 video and think
about how you can apply it to your life
if you learned a little bit from Donald
Trump and a little bit from Steve Jobs
and a little bit when Oprah Winfrey
you'll make yourself better and so I've
profiled controversial people on the
channel on purpose like Donald Trump I
think you can learn a lot from people
who you initially disagree with so
someone like Trump I don't agree with a
lot of his politics I don't agree with a
lot of how he talks to people and treats
people but it doesn't mean that I can't
learn from some of the things that he's
really good at I'm a Canadian you know I
have no stake in the election I didn't
have a vote if you asked Canadians what
did Donald Trump stand for what was one
of his campaign policies you think about
the wall right it was a clear easy to
understand concept did I agree with the
wall probably not but you understood
that's what he stood for if you think
about how he labelled the competitors he
was up against if you think about
crooked Hillary as an example do I like
how he is slamming people and being
really negative and name-calling
no but you remember it if we think about
what was one campaign policy that
Hillary Clinton stood for I can't tell
you and it's not because she didn't have
great ones it's just the positioning
wasn't fantastic and so a lot of what
Donald Trump is great at he may use in
ways that I disagree with but I can
learn from them to use them in a
positive way for myself and if you want
to beat Donald Trump you should learn
how he's using those techniques so that
you can beat him because everybody
underestimated him all the way through
and so I fundamentally just believed
that if somebody has accomplished
something that you haven't they've had
some success you could learn from them
even if 95% of what they're saying you
fundamentally disagree with you could
still pull something from them and use
it in a positive way to help you be the
best version of yourself and so you have
to understand that you're gonna win by
be
you as kind of cheesy as that sounds and
as often as we hear by all these
celebrities and entrepreneurs we profile
on this channel you win by being you but
you don't know who you is yet you don't
know what the best version of you looks
like yet and at least my way of figuring
that out is making these videos to run
to myself with these people who've
accomplished a lot of success and
listening to each point I'm trying to
think about can I apply this to my life
I read a page from this book the top ten
was a success every single day and I
think about how can I apply one of these
things to my life these are some of the
greatest things that these most
successful people ever have said you
know take three minutes and just think
about can I apply this to my life
somehow and some of them you might look
at and say I already know that I'm
already doing that and some of you might
say well I totally disagree with that if
you already knew it and you already had
that supreme confidence you probably
wouldn't be in a situation right now
you'd be on the same level of
accomplishment of success of achievement
as the people you're looking up to and
so I find that taking three minutes just
to reflect on it and think how can this
make me better quite often I get some
surprising ideas that allow me to push
forward and actually become better so I
have a special bonus clip for you guys
but before getting to it I have a
special question for you question the
day is I'm curious what is something
that you have learned from somebody else
that has made you a better version of
you
what if you model from somebody else
maybe on this channel maybe somewhere
else you really took home and it helped
you understand yourself better leave it
down in the comments below I'm really
curious to see what you have to say
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus
let's pray so give me go
I hold in my hand chocolate chips
chocolate chip cookies right now what's
interesting is this is just an example
of when you go to any supermarket
there is a whole aisle dedicated to
chocolate chip cookies you can get
whatever flavor or everstyle you want
but what dawned on me is that you mean
to tell me there's a whole aisle of the
same product so as I I sat there looking
at the aisle I said how is it possible
in almost every supermarket in the
country there can be an aisle dedicated
to the same product as I began to think
about it I said it might be the same
chocolate chip but what differentiates
one brand from another the recipe may I
submit for your consideration these
chocolate chip cookies represent success
we all have been destined to be
successful but each one of us has a
different recipe that God will use to
create success what I know is that
Keebler ain't trying to steal mrs.
Fields recipe because Keebler does what
they do mrs. Fields do what they do and
they both can sell millions of cookies
every single year why because they're
committed to their recipe they believe
that their recipe is the best and as a
result they still find success you don't
see on the package of mrs. Fields we
taste just like a blurs now mrs. fields
as mrs. Fields Keebler's as mrs. tailors
and Chips Ahoy as Chips Ahoy Oh your
difference is
Destinee you have a recipe for your
success so why are you over there trying
to steal your neighbor's recipe why
don't you start cooking up what God gave
you start mixing up your ingredients and
know that if your neighbor can find
space on the Isle of the world for
success that God has some shelf space
for you too because here's the thing I
only got one life this is not a dress
rehearsal can I remind you of that you
don't get a chance to do this life over
again this is the show you're waiting to
perform the performance is now so if you
don't live out your truth if you don't
embrace your difference will you be able
to look back and say whatever you
shortchange your difference for it was
worth it whoever you shortchange your
difference for were they worth it so
often we become a limited version of
ourselves just to be accepted by
somebody who then goes on to move on to
somebody else and there we are left with
the damage of having compromised
ourselves for their love and acceptance
and they decide no no and they're on to
somebody else and we're still left
healing from a situation we should have
never been in to begin with say yeah
your notes Devon I just need to tell you
right now please do not want love so
badly you compromised who you are to get
it if somebody you're dating cannot
handle the fullness of your purpose and
your calling and your personality why
don't you go ahead and drop them right
now please drop them cut it off cut it
off why because all you're doing is
wasting your time and their time be who
you're created to be and if they cannot
handle that god bless them go ahead and
buy my bag of cookies and say I'll see
you on the other side but I cannot allow
myself to be subject to your limited
thinking I am bigger than your capacity
to handle Who I am Who am I talking to
right now your difference is your
destiny stop trying so hard to be
someone you're not
stop trying so hard period you don't
have to I remember
constantly feeling like I wasn't I
wasn't what was expected
and a lot of that had to do with my skin
color a lot of that it feel so stupid
but a lot of it feels I had to do with
not feeling black enough like I was the
right kind of black like I wasn't cool
enough
like I wasn't fun enough like I wasn't I
just wasn't good enough or what what was
being painted of me just even on
television and music and that was really
disheartening and I would tell my
younger self now that you don't need to
be that it's totally fine like
everything's gonna be okay and I
honestly embrace who you are now embrace
what makes you different you don't have
people don't have to if people don't
like you for who you are and then those
people aren't meant to be in your life
you don't want them there anyway so stop
trying to impress people by being
someone you're not raise your standard
apple at the core its core value is that
people with passion not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your acceptance a
man
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details